how's it going brother and today I'm
here with my one true and only love and
care my two Luck's we're gonna play
three games
[Music]
[Applause]
whatever wins the most points wins has
to kiss Edgar's bye
no way and here's like one week okay so
you can choose one of these controls
okay you have to dodge the cars you did
[Music]
this is so intense
oh god this is so scary it goes faster
and faster Hey
[Music]
yeah well I'm surprised you haven't done
yet oh god we don't like something no
warning was a oh oh this one's slow you
just go slow and then oh well I'm hit no
I'm robbing oh you did it
so since we both hit at the same time
this is sudden death so we could both
get one point here you really want to
win huh looks like you're gonna have to
kiss my ass you son of them nothing
[Applause]
next game is next game is tough touch
next
do you remember those tongues that you
like you buying machines and you cannot
both players hold trigger to start this
trigger engage both both players hold
trigger thank you
all right here we go I'm ready you're
going down you roll again this is like
the new super Spanish precious I think I
think we're playing two at the same time
wait one second green
what the hell we are no you're I'm
winning look at it no I'm red green frog
wins devil its first two three no no
winner all right you got a star good job
what do you want I smack your head like
I smack your ass every day
yeah we're frogs you're right alright I
thought it was those smacking EMU cos I
think I'm winning this one I think I'm
winning
[Music]
yeah so one one whoever wins this one
wins
oh no let me go back stop thinking like
oh you're not a Viking alright you're a
peasant a lien woman same know your
place can I see some Oh what are you
going good
[Music]
[Applause]
are we recording at all yeah so this one
you might like because it's called
wedding simulator all women love
weddings this is a common fact I love
princess diary okay it's not my fault
operative experience prepare for your
greatest journey so this might actually
not be a competition use arrow keys and
spacebar to play so I think we take
turns to play and I think I you start
actually yeah play one that's you yeah
will you marry me oh sure come play -
sure say sir your pregame you have to
get drunk that's a big glass underneath
there you go wow so good that was good
job pay the stripper it's my turn all
right yeah pull the money right in that
booty that paint booty I'm gonna yes
they go right inside and anus
say oh I'm amazing gussied up all right
make yourself pretty girl Wow hip number
six damage sacrifice to the better white
[Applause]
with this ring what what am i Miriam
here the goat ah sorry you two are not
compatible
shiny ball you want to try the Navy I
can't contain okay let's play me that
again I'll be the girl all right you
want to play cards play alright alright
you're on the girl alright this is how
your door your pour it in my aim and
then you drink it oh yeah drink take all
those shots passion that's right that's
how you do it
passion Wow we're doing great parents I
love you
I don't forget married someday look
yeah we're compatible compatible shave
that mustache shaved that mustache girl
cheek that mustache Oh chick that much
nice I'm sucking its shaving the bud
stage don't worry I sacrifice the late
Jimmy see this one is impossible stupid
game
alright you know what that one doesn't
count I don't know what fight me fight
me woman I mean there must yeah I'm what
there must be some way to what is going
on and I feel hi you got a crapshoot
more oh I think I think a friend of
mine knows
I wanna make this game I'm so confused I
want ya know I'm red time I'm digging on
you take it out
red crab like me you know this video if
you did hit that like button stay
awesome bros and hoes and protect shows
[Music]